the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another wins of winner and a
song of ice and fire update video all
right my friends in this video we will
be looking at the very recent update
released by george rr martin on his not
a blog website once again george r
martin mentions the wins of winner
therefore i must say something about it
let's have a look at what he said on his
website the main reason why he wrote
this blog was to inform everyone about
the work that has been done on the sky
railway a historic short haul railroad
he has invested in he goes on to say
that he almost named the update i've
been working on the railroad but my
readers would have taken that the wrong
way and anyway it isn't true i am one of
the owners
mostly what i have been doing is
throwing out ideas and writing checks
skye's employees an energetic and
enthusiastic crew have been doing the
work all those things i mentioned up
above and lots more besides i have not
driven a single spike laid a single rail
reupholstered a seat or crawled under a
coach to check the wheels and i won't be
selling tickets or driving the trains
either though i do reserve the right to
blow the whistle now and again nor have
i been in the kitchen with dina i have
been working yes yes but not on the
railroad i have been writing the winds
of winter editing three new wild cards
books sitting down with some amazing
screenwriters and showrunners to create
317 new game of thrones successor shows
for hbo and hbo max and serving as
executive producer on other television
and film projects and various stages of
development including dark wings for amc
joker town for peacock road marks and
who fears death for hbo
oh and i was the executive producer on
our recently rapped short film of howard
waldrop's night of the cooters so i have
been working maybe too bloody hard but
that's another tale for another blog
though these days even finding the time
to blog is hard but i digress
so as you can see the winds of winter is
barely even mentioned which is
understandable because he is working on
so many other things now he says that
finding the time to blog is hard but i'm
wondering where he even finds the time
to write the ones of winner when he is
working on all of these other things
that he seems to be more interested in
and excited about these days
[Laughter]
does anyone else wish that george would
let us know exactly how much more he
needs to write before he finishes the
wins of winner now i know i know he
doesn't owe us anything but it would be
nice if he would occasionally let us
know how much more he has left to write
before he can release his next book if
you're someone who watches all of my
update videos or at the very least
someone who follows george rr martin's
not a blog website then you will know
that he has given us several updates
over the year regarding the winds of
winter every once in a while he will
reveal some information about how much
he has been writing but since he has
missed deadline after deadline his
updates are becoming more and more vague
as a matter of fact he hardly even
mentions the wins of winner anymore now
you know before game of thrones ended i
would have said the winds of winter is
arguably one of the most highly
anticipated books of the century almost
every game of thrones in a song of ice
and fire fan was anxiously awaiting for
its release but now i'm not so sure and
i say that because i see what a lot of
the fans say whenever i make a video on
this subject unfortunately there are
many fans who believe we will never see
the wins of winner as you all know
george rr martin has been writing the
wins of winner for well over a decade
now and there are many different
theories surrounding why he hasn't
finished it yet some fans say he has
lost interest while others say he is
waiting to finish a dream of spring so
he can release them at once well based
on this update alone i don't think we
should expect it anytime soon he has his
hands and so many other things i don't
see when he will ever get around to
finishing the story which is very very
unfortunate considering it has been
beloved by so many fans for so long all
we can do now is hope that one day his
interest for a song of ice and fire will
be reignited somehow some way
[Music]
you